Hello Freak bitches.
Look how big this Paris like,
wait,
wait to see this video.
You're going to shit your pants.
So it goes.
Go fullscreen,
Jamie.
It's not going full screen.
Here you go.
You're going to shit your pants to
Swedish man.
So this guy,
he sees it in the woods and he starts
running up to him.
Whereas the volume buddy,
it's all wintery wise.
No sound.
It was definitely sound.
We got to hear the sound because the guy
screams at it.
Hold on.
We got to figure out how it worked.
Holy Shit.
I never saw.
I never even thought that would work.
What's up?
What's definitely got sound?
So let's figure it out because you got
to hear it because the guy goes,
well look,
I'll put his arms out to the side.
Look at the size of it.
It's running at him,
like running at him and he was able to
scare it.
He,
he reels back like he's scared.
Well he went for it,
you know,
look,
look bad.
I was like,
Oh shit,
look it up.
Look how big he is and look how much
bigger that thing.
It's like four times,
five times bigger than him.
Oh my God.
That makes me freak out.
If he had turned and Ronnie would have
been eating.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
I mean,
the thing ran at him like it was dinner
time.
I was that close to a bear.
Where in Alaska and Denali.
Jesus.
A grizzly.
Yup.
What the big ass grizzly.
We woke up in the morning and uh,
we were in back country for a couple of
weeks just hiking and walking around and
um,
we got,
we woke up and we were making her
breakfast and we look up on a ridge and
there's this big ass bear.
This is September,
so it's like late,
you know,
it's like they were getting ready to
hibernate and he's walking down the
ridge and as we're packing up and uh,
you know,
up the Ridge is actually where we were
cleaning our dishes and doing all this
stuff.
And now we're back at camp.
We're breaking down to hike out and we
see this thing go walking down.
Just dumb asses.
We're so lucky we didn't get eaten.
The Guy,
the,
uh,
we pack up and we just start walking in
the same direction that the bear was
going.
We were like,
he's not going to be going.
He,
he probably,
he's beaten us there.
So we're walking through these,
these reads,
these bamboo kind of little reads,
but there were only like six feet high
and there's like eight of us,
maybe six of us and we're walking with
our packs on and you just hear and you
see the reeds separating slowly though,
like it's not coming fast.
Just like,
what the hell?
That's probably the bear.
We see that it's the bear and you know,
you're supposed to do with that guy did
put your arms up or at least freeze and
don't see everyone in the group took
off.
That's the one thing I ran all my frozen
in the pose.
Me and my one friend,
like you're not supposed to do the we
run at,
we're in and they take off with their
backpacks,
but the bear,
thankfully just by a stroke of luck,
this thing was so fat and tired and the
end of September he just wanted to go
down low,
gets some more berries and take a
snooze.
Was not interested in us at all.
He was just so lucky.
So lucky.
But I swear to God it was for me to the
end of this table.
Yeah.
Well when they're,
when they're gathering berries,
that's when your safest.
They get in their head that that's what
they want to eat and they eat a lot of
bearings.
He did not.
He was not interested to fuck all that.
So close animals.
I mean I love the the there.
I think it's cool,
but God dammit,
they scare the shit out of me.
It was a video of these guys.
They're hanging out by this river and
they have like a little lawn chair and
this bear is enormous.
Crazy bear just walks up and sits down
next to them.
Have you seen that one Jamie?
Close encounter with grit.
Grizzly bear casually walks up to people
and they just had to talk to them.
They're like,
hey man,
get the fuck out of here.
And the bar just gets up and leaves.
But I mean,
he's like a school bus.
It's like a minivan.
I always describe it like a minivan.
Did you find one?
Yeah.
This is it.
Look at this.
Wow.
Look at the size of this.
Just sat next to his chair.
He just pulls up to his chair.
A beautiful animal.
They'll look at that thing.
Oh my.
There's the gorgeous dead do.
If that's you,
you can't do shit.
Can't do shit because you don't want to
provoke it.
No,
no.
You definitely don't want to back up.
That thing is just chasing salmon right
now.
Yeah.
You don't want to yell at it.
As long as you don't hit it doesn't
think you're a threat.
They're really dumb,
right?
In their mind.
Yeah.
I'm not dumb.
Like.
No.
I mean like,
like dumb.
Like if they were a person they'd be
retarded.
Right?
They're bold,
they're simple.
They're predators.
You know,
they get in their head like what they
want to do.
Oh my God,
he's just sitting down.
This is awesome.
Just decided,
chill.
What a clear shot look at is,
look at his claws.
One Swipe.
I mean your faces off.
The guys filming this is 10 feet away
from him.
He's right there and the eventually
talks to him.
He was like,
Hey,
get out of here.
Like the bear looks at him like we
really got close.
It is the bear.
Looks like a little annoyed for a
second.
Do the thing.
Just wandered towards him.
Seriously.
Oh my God.
They're everywhere.
Now I don't even feel bad for that guy.
Back that up.
Like why should they go to the river?
This case,
sitting with a lawn chair by the river
while one,
two.
Let's see.
Three,
four,
five,
six.
And that one said,
oh my God.
Oh God,
there's a dozen baird's a dozen.
Massive grizzly bears.
Oh my God.
I'm so scared.
I got this more.
Look at those other two.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine,
10,
11.
Oh my God.
How funny if you pull back and the guy
with the camera is a bear.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
That's amazing.
Oh my God.
They're the coolest animal.
My favorite animal.
Do you God damn cool until they're
eating you?
Yeah,
and that's so cool.
Now.